Okay.
Yeah.
My previous lessons with debt arguments and truth and logic and they introduced
the difference between truth and validity.
In evaluating an argument.
As you may have noticed,
neither of the language of logic nor the ways of forming and analyzing an
argument guarantee the truth of the statements,
the premise season conclusion.
Within that argument,
the toolkit of logic doesn't generate truth.
Instead,
it allows statements to remain true throughout the process of developing an
argument.
We might call it truth preserving rather than truth producing.
We can analyze the function of every one of the operators you learned in the
logic as a language series within that context of truth preservation.
This is normally done using something called a truth table.
So far speaking,
generally I've been careful to separate content from form.
Now let's move towards integrating these two aspects of statements.
By considering truth values,
I'll be using just two basic values,
true and false.
To start with the simple analogy,
this is like a light switch with the value on or off the switch sends a signal
to a light which may also be on or off the switches.
A variable.
In a statement like a proposition p,
the light is the value of the entire statement.
If I give you two statements,
p and Q,
can you tell me what they mean?
No,
because they're just variables and you don't know what they represent.
So then can you say nothing about their content?
Think for a moment in the lesson on arguments,
we looked at an argument with the form p implies Q,
p,
therefor Q.
It's well formed meaning if we fill it with true statements,
the conclusion will be entailed.
It is possible to say something about p then it can be true or it can be false.
And the same goes for Q.
By looking at the operators and the form of the argument,
we can pass that truth down to the conclusion.
Well,
we don't know the specific value of p or Q.
We can say things that hold for every possible truth,
value in combination and declare the resulting truth value of the statement as a
whole.
If p is true,
then the statement p is true.
If p is true and Q is true,
then the statement p and Q is true.
If p is false and Q is false,
p and Q is false.
See you can say about the truth of the statements.
We're going to dive into specifics but first let's test to see if you get the
gist of logical values.
Assume p and Q,
Stanford,
two different random propositions or sentences.
I'm going to give you a value for P and a value for queue and you'll tell me if
the statement that follows is true.
Let's say we have a proposition.
Pete,
I'm going to bring back our light switch analogy.
P is a switch and p can be on or off.
The negation not turns the value of p around.
If p is true then not p is false and vice versa.
If we add another not the negation is negated,
so not not p is true when p is true and false.
When p is false,
the conjunction and joins two propositions,
so you have to pay attention to both of their truth values.
P may be true when Q is true,
false when Q is true and so on.
As we've seen before.
The statement p and Q will only be true if both p and Q are true.
In all other cases it is false.
The light is lit only when both switches are on.
Hm.
Inclusive or is true when either p Q or both p and Q are true.
The light goes on when at least one switch is flipped.
Okay.
On the other hand,
xclusive or expects that either one or the other statement is true but it is
false when both statements are true.
As a reminder,
this is the kind of or you use when you ask do you want to leave today or
tomorrow where you exclude the possibility of today and tomorrow the light turns
on when either one of the switches is flipped.
Okay.
The logical implication is frequently used and for some learners it's a bit
tricky.
If p is true,
then Q is true meaning p implies Q holds.
If p and Q are both true,
p implies Q is false.
If p is true and to Q is false in that case p wouldn't imply queue.
It would imply not queue.
If p is false and Q is false,
then p could still very well imply cue.
So the implication holds true.
The last case where P is false and Q is true is an interesting one.
Something besides p might imply cue.
So the implication still holds.
P implies Q holds true and less ps true and Q is false.
This is like a light that goes on when switch P is on.
If the switches on than we expect the light to be on,
but the light might also turn on from some other switch.
So the switch p being off doesn't make the statement.
If piece flipped on,
then the light is on untrue.
Only one thing can make that statement if pees on the light is on false turning
p on and finding the light off.
Finally,
the bike conditional means that the two propositions,
p and Q have the same value.
The statement p if and only if Q is true when both p and Q are true or both p
and Q are false.
In any other case,
the bike conditional is false.
This makes the two propositions logically equivalent,
so they must return the same value.
I encourage you to go back through these operators filling in p cubed with
propositions you take to be true or false and spend some time reflecting on the
logical truth values.
If the result is a statement,
this will be a good exercise.
It'll help you familiarize yourself with truth tables and clear up some
ambiguities in your logic.
Please take a moment to check out the playlists on my youtube channel or the
lessons on native lane.com for more logic and language resources.
As always,
thanks for learning with me.
Yeah.